انتكاسات عسكريه روسيه في الاشهر الاخيره
في اوكرانيا اعاده موسكو لمربع التلويح
بترسانتها النوويه في محاوله لتغيير وضعها
الميدانيه عدونا ليس متواجدا في الخنادق
فقط في محافظتك انه موجود في اوروبا
وامريكا الشماليه واليابان واستراليا
وانيوزيلندا وغيرها لهذا نقوم بتكثيف
انتاج اقوى وسائل التدمير
روسيا تقولوا انها ستلجا لمبادئ جديده لم
توضحها لكن الحديث على الاغلب يدور حول
تكتيك الترهيب الروسي بشبح الحرب النوويه
في محاوله لفرض صفقه مع الغرب الرئيس
الروسي بلادي مربوط باستخدامه تحت ذريعه
ان السلاح النوويه يعد وسيله دفاع الغايه
منها توجيه ضربه الانتقاميه في حال
استهدفت بلاده بهذا النوع من الاسلحه
وروسيا تعملوا على تعديل عقيدتها العسكريه
بالاعتماد على الاجيال الجديده من الاسلحه
التي تفوق يعدها سرعه الصوت حسب البيانات
المعلنه للتسلح النووي العالمي منها التي
نشرتها منظمه اي كان فان روسيا تمتلك اكبر
ترسانه نوويه في العالم اذ يبلغ عدد
الرؤوس النوويه الحربيه لديها سته الاف
ومائتين و 255 راس نووويا منها
1588 جاهزا للاطلاق معظمها صواريخ موجهه
لاهداف بعيده المدى وعدد اخر اصغر حجما
واقل تدميرا تستهدف الاهداف قصيره المدى
في ساحه المعركه او في البحر
وسط التلميح النووي الروسي الدول الغربيه
تقف ممدده باستخفاف روسيا بخطوره الوضع
محضره نياها بعدم استغلال محادثات سلام
اوكرانيا كغطاء لاعاده التسلح او التخطيط
لهجوم اكبر